what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
want to try something new here on on
comment explained but for the most part
when it comes to character discussions
we do like these great big huge
elaborate discussions on things but the
most popular characters and pretty much
all the characters that we're gonna
discuss over the course these videos
have already been talked about
I mean we've we've already done those
big character discussions so there's no
sense in going back and doing them again
I want these to be a series of videos
that serve no other purpose than to get
you prepared for Marvel legacy so you
can go and immediately start reading the
comics and know exactly what to expect
or at the very least have a perfect
understanding we're near perfect
understanding of what's going on in the
stories and what's coming down the
pipeline so in this video we're gonna
focus on Iron Man now this all really
goes back to 2013 when a guy named Karen
Gillan took over the iron man stories
what Karen Gillan did is he basically
introduced a couple of different things
but the biggest thing that we need to
worry about is a character named Arno
stark what happened is curing Gillan
crafted this great big huge epic called
the ax the secret origin of Tony Stark
and it introduced this idea that Tony
himself was not actually the biological
child of Howard and Maria instead he was
adopted the biological child of Howard
in Moorea was a guy named Arno Stark
another stark was basically this super
smart guy and different things like that
but he was kept hidden just because of
the fact that there was some things that
Howard ámoreá did that they didn't want
anybody else to know and they were
basically just keeping our know hidden
away from the rest of the world the
specifics as to why that is are both
covered in this video and they'll also
be covered once Arno actually comes out
in the comics the long and short of it
was that Arno was basically genetically
engineered and the person who
genetically engineered him could not
know that Howard ámoreá made adjustments
to the genes of Arno himself and that's
really about it but Arno just remained
hidden for decades he was literally just
sitting in this hospital more or less
that had been established in the name of
Howard of Moria and nobody ever knew
about him Tony didn't even know about it
and so because this are now basically
had like a pretty cool role to play he
was more of like a background character
for the Ironman stories in the sense
that he helped Tony Stark with a wide
array of different things the extremest
tech for example the technology that
allows Ironman to merge directly with
his own suit and it also has a lot of
other practical purposes but Arno
vanished during the events of all-new
all-different marvel he's not been seen
or heard from since and we have no idea
what happened to him but we know he will
be explored as part of Marvel leg
so that's the reason why I bring him up
another thing and this is what hits home
at the idea of math fractions room back
in 2008 this is something called stark
resilient stark resilient was a concept
created by Tony Stark for the purposes
of being a branch off from his own Stark
Industries Stark Industries focus of
focuses on weapons manufacturing stark
resilient focuses on things like
technology for society better phones and
devices and all different manner of
things the idea was that Pepper Potts
who had long since been the assistant of
Tony Stark was elevated to CEO of stark
Brasilia now this was done just because
of the fact that her being associated
with Tony as part of Stark Industries
made her a target for a lot of villains
and so ultimately Tony put her in charge
of stark resilient what this did is this
ran all the way through the secret
origin of Tony Stark the introduction of
our now and into something called
superior Iron Man
now superior Iron Man was this story
where it basically came as an aftermath
to axis axis was a story that dealt with
the idea that the Red Skull had gotten
the brain of Charles Xavier who'd been
killed by Cyclops and basically just
like went on a rampage it took like dr.
strange and the Scarlet Witch to use
magic to try to invert red skull make
him a good guy the spell infected
everybody so all the good guys became
bad guys all bad guys became good guys
when everything was supposed to go back
to normal
Tony Stark's shielded himself and so
what ended up happening is that when the
Karen Gillan run of Iron Man ended it
ended before Secret Wars 2015 started
and so Marvel would have had like nine
months of no stories involving Iron Man
and so what they did is they went to a
guy named Han Taylor and just said give
us an Iron Man story we don't care what
it is it's gotta be tied into axis
somehow it has to be an aftermath to
axis because that's the big event that
he was just involved in give us
something and so Tom Taylor had
basically written a story called
superior Iron Man where it detailed the
events that 20 stars went through after
shielding himself and basically
remaining a bad guy so he went
full-blown back into alcoholism he was a
total jerk to basically everybody he
alienated Pepper Potts she didn't want
to have anything to do with him and then
the story just ended because Secret Wars
2015 happened so we got no real
resolution to and I mean we did in the
sense that the version of Iron Man that
fights Captain America when the
multiverse is coming to an end that's
basically superior Iron Man but going
into all-new all-different marvel Tony
Stark was back to his normal self with
no real explanation as to why but there
were some things that lingered over for
example Pepper Potts still wanted
nothing to do with Iron Man whatsoever
and because Pepper Potts didn't want to
have anything to do with him what ended
up happening is right of Ryan Michael
Bendis reached out and grabbed Mary Jane
Watson from the spider-man comics and
roll her over into the Iron Man comics
Mary Jane Watson basically became the
new Pepper Potts she was the assistant
behind the scenes helping to run the
company and different things like that
while Tony Stark was off doing his own
thing at the same time while we had the
invincible Iron Man stories we also had
a story called International Iron Man an
International Iron Man basically was a
seven issue miniseries that did nothing
more than detail Tony Stark's search for
his biological parents and he found his
mom and that's it that's the only thing
you need to worry about
he found his mom his mom came back she
hung hangs out at Stark Industries and
that's it there's really nothing else go
now following the first six or seven
issues of invincible Iron Man what ended
up happening is Marvel launched a story
called civil war - and Civil War to you
was designed to do nothing more than
just capitalize on the popularity of the
Civil War movie from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the problem was that
the story was fleshed out over the
course of three months for those of you
guys who were new to Marvel Comics
usually when a company sits down Marvel
DC whoever when they sit down and they
say okay we want to do a great big huge
grandiose event whether it's the
original Civil War from back in 2005
2006 whether it is the house of M when
all the mutants lose their powers
whatever the case may be they usually
sit down like 1 or 2 years in advance
and like flesh the whole thing out what
all the tie ins are gonna be all that
kind of good stuff
Civil War - did not receive that
treatment the movie was made everything
was fleshed out over three months and
then all the stories were just thrown in
and that was it and so because of that
it was not really well-received because
it felt rushed but the overall gist of
Civil War 2 was that there was an
inhuman named Ulysses who claimed he
could see the future and in some
instances he was right in some instances
he was wrong but what it did is it split
the community down the middle on one
half you had Carol Danvers Captain
Marvel who believed they should just
take his visions at face value and
assume they're absolutely true on the
other side you had Tony Stark who said
no we should at least check to see
whether or not he's absolutely right
100% of the time before we just assume
that he's right 100% of the time and so
ultimately at the end of Civil War to
Tony Stark died and so his body was just
sort of thrown in stasis and that was
really about it he was just kind of
tossed in this system where he was just
kind of kept on ice until such a time as
he could be revived or until writer
Brian Michael Bendis wanted to bring him
back and so in place of Tony Stark dying
we got two new versions of Iron Man the
first is the one that everybody
complains about and the second is the
one that nobody complains about so the
first one that people always complain
about is riri Williams in the sense that
she's basically a girl who was able to
duplicate Tony Stark's armor and Brian
Michael Bendis used this as a means to
grab the character and then roll her
over into being the new Iron Man now the
part that people complain about is the
idea that well is a diversity push for
the for the sake of diversity and you
know what they did it too fast Tim Drake
became Robin and six issues in the DC
and DC Comics so I don't understand that
complaint but the idea here is that Ruby
William it's basically became the new
Iron Man
and so Tony Stark just kind of remained
on ice he had backed up his mind to an
artificial intelligence and he was the
AI inside her suit so he would basically
train her guide her teacher how to be a
superhero different things like that the
other version of Iron Man was Doctor
Doom and that version was covered in a
story called infamous Iron Man and that
basically just detailed the idea that
after the events of Secret Wars 2015
when Doctor Doom had essentially become
God and then lost his powers after being
defeated by Reed Richards but he had
gone on this quest of a redemption of
source and so he was basically acting as
Iron Man with a really really
cool-looking outfit and then just either
being a superhero or interacting with
other characters but it was really more
like a personal quest the return of dr.
Doom's mom different things like that
it's really some of the best
storytelling involving his character
that I've seen since the events of like
Hickman's Avengers and new Avengers and
like books of doom that focus on his
origin and then of course the events of
Secret Wars respectively but the idea
here is that as part of Marvel legacy
there are a handful of things that are
gonna happen having said all that the
first is that Arno stark will be
revisited that something that Brian
Michael Bendis the writer of Iron Man
has stated that Otto Stark will be
revisited again eventually he'll come
back and we'll find out what's been
going on with him all this time the
second is that Tony Stark
has returned but we don't know how we
don't know where he is but the new story
arc for part of Marvel legacy is the
search for Tony Stark
so essentially what had happened in the
Marvel Legacy one-shot is that somebody
had gone in they've gone to check on the
case of Tony Stark where his body was
being held and he just vanished and
nobody knew where he went to and so
that's the new story just to see what in
the world happened to him where he's
gone and then eventually he'll probably
go back to being Iron Man again the
other thing is that we will also see a
little more expansion when it comes to
the character of Tony Stark's mom we'll
see a little love a few more things
expanded on that the thing to keep in
mind though is that in some of the books
Marvel's going by weekly which means the
releasing them every two weeks
I think Iron Man is one of them because
he's just so popular I know the Avengers
is one of them and there may be a few
others so usually because of the fact of
these story arcs lasts anywhere between
you know five to six issues will
basically end up seeing this whole thing
resolved at the latest in six months at
the earliest in three months but we just
got a whole bunch of dead space between
the time this issue number one comes out
and the time' trees
she's got a lot of time but the fact
remains here that's essentially the long
and short of what's going on right now
that essentially Tony Stark is back
weary Williams is still Iron Man for dr.
doom is still infamous Iron Man he'll
play a role in the ongoing invincible
Iron Man story we will see the brother
of Tony Stark come back we may end up
seen Pepper Potts realign herself with
Tony Stark we don't know those are the
kind of things that were just kind of
waiting to see or that we know what will
happen but anyway guys if you are new
here to come this explain and you guys
enjoy these kind of videos let me know
you know leave a comment down below or
drop a like or something like that and
if you are new here and you dig stuff
like this then make sure you get the sub
button to become part of the Rob port
and yeah this is actually kind of fun I
like doing this this is pretty
interesting just a quick no frills
explanation on what's been happening
over the course of the last few years of
Marvel Comics when it comes to the
launch of Marvel legacy so anyway guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and I will catch you all later peace
[Music]